all right who said a fun Halloween can't
be a healthy one two registered
dietitian Mia sin is here in studio Not
museum or via video with sweets and
snacks for the entire family or the
entire party whatever you're doing at
home this Halloween yes I'm so excited
you look good oh thanks
in studio I was teasing him because he
gets this every day he's getting lucky
this is amazing okay let's talk about
how we're making fun snacks fun okay so
this is a Halloween snack bar and you
want to go in with your like red or
sorry orange and black of course so
we're gonna start with our nutritious
dips hummus I'm a huge fan
um you know this is the fresh crimmings
hummus it's made with a short list of
high quality whole food ingredients
Chilean extra virgin olive oil chickpea
tahini you can find on the deli section
at Walmart fun flavors like everything
bagel honey jalapeno salsa is another
nutritious option low calories chilled
in the produce section at Walmart then
we have some black grapes cheese is a
good source of protein you want your
crunchy components yeah whenever I just
this chip right here is so amazing so
these are pop chips they're kind of a
better for you salty snack popped
instead of fried half the fat of your
fried potato chips these are so fun
they're these single serve pouches you
can get these in a 30 count variety pack
at Sam's Club
um
so good you can dip them you know and
then of course we have our grapes yeah I
love that you you know like obviously
the colors of the Season you found in
colors of the season in season so kind
of a fun snacking idea I love it um this
is another fun snacking idea these are
low calorie ghost meringues so really
easy to make you're going to start with
your meringue meringues these are tidbit
meringue drops okay these are they have
two calories each or less than two
calories and less than 80 calories per
pouch what are they made of what did
some meringues are made of like egg
whites typically
um really easy to make at home actually
but I like these because they come in
different flavors like birthday cake
um these are I think are or like cookies
and cream there's
and those come in regular diabetic or
keto friendly varieties okay and you did
the fun little eyes for the ghosts yes
and my fiance helped me with that so
very props to him yeah may I try one yes
absolutely so yeah these are you know
fun to make with your kids too like a
whatever you sweet snack less than two
calories each I was not expecting that
it just melts in your mouth okay
so this is one of my favorite recipes in
my new book
um these are banana sweet and chocolate
chip oatmeal cookies so you're gonna
start with two bananas to have them mash
and then you're gonna go in with one
teaspoon of pure vanilla extract this is
from the vanilla extract company they
have a whole line of sustainable high
quality Madagascar Source vanilla
products including these Gourmet grade a
vanilla beans you can Unleash Your
creativity in the kitchen use your ice
cream cocktails have fun with the kids
helping you make them and everything of
course if this is the kids party oh yeah
but it's also perfect for an adult yes
both yes goes for everybody everyone
peanut butter
um some chocolate chips and then oats I
use quick oats and regular rolled oats
mix that together and usually have like
a fork to mash it yeah and then you're
going to just form them into cookies
bake that for 12 minutes at 350 degrees
Fahrenheit and they're getting most of
their sweetness from bananas so good I
love them Mia you have all the best tips
thank you for this where can people find
you nutritionbymia.com on Instagram
thank you girl we'll be right back on
Las Vegas now